après 8 mois d'absence Alex metteyer
revient en force à Bobino il est ce soir
notre invité et invité de Catherine pic
pour un nouveau spectacle qui est aussi
vous allez le voir une affaire de
famille de travailler avec son fils mais
c'est bien parce que ça a cassé tous les
rapports le peu de rapports qui restaiit
père
fils ont été complètement brisés parce
que avoir son fils qui dit Alex non pas
ici là non non non non du côté du piano
non et a tout un coup je me suis senti
élève de mon fils c'était très très bien
j'ai j'ai beaucoup aimé ces rapports
parce que erriic est a été constamment
sur la même longueur d'onde avec moi si
les enfants ont une place importante
c'est parce que les enfants sont de bons
comédiens et j'aime bien mettre en scène
des enfants parce que il y a un une
gesticulation excessive par exemple dans
mord d'ORAC le gosse il devient un
monstre une espèce de de folie comme ça
qu'on retrouve le plus chez l'adulte
parce que l'adulte se contrôle ou par
exemple dans dans un des sketchs
l'enfant est à l'école et à l'école il
est interrogé par tous les professeurs
et on le voit toute la série des
expressions dans le visage qui passent
de la naïveté du jeune poète puisque je
suis un jeune poète et jusqu'au moment
où les professeurs finissant par le
stresser il devient une espèce de
prisonnier prisonnier toutes les
questions qu'on lui pose alors il y a
toute une variation dans l'expression
que je pouvais trouver chez l'enfant
c'est pour ça que l'enfant est très
utilisé et puis il y a le problème du
racisme alors le problème du racisme
j'ai voulu montrer comment le racisme
est insidieux et le texte commence comme
ça euh Mohamed est-ce que pourriez nous
parler du présent de l'indicatif ouais
monsieur je peux je peux voà présent
ngatif je me promène dans la rue les
oiseaux chantent c'est le printemps il y
en a des jeunes filles jolies très
jolies il y en a qui rendent dans un bal
j'y veux rentrer moi aussi il y a le
patron qui dit non tu rentres pas ça
c'est la forme négative très négative tu
rent pas moi j'ai dit et pourquoi j'y
rent pas alors ça c'est la forme
interrogative qui appelle une réponse
non t etappelle les flic voyez c'est un
peu une espèce de de de bataille entre
un professeur donc qui est moi dans le
dans le spectacle qui veut apporter la
culture à un arabe et l'arabe lui il
amène ses véritables problème voilà
qu'est-ce qui vous inspire le plus ce
qui m'inspire c'est ce que je vois dans
la vie c'est-à-dire mes familiers ça
peut être vous ça peut être le caméraman
ça peut être demain je prends des notes
comme ça des fois un geste un geste par
exemple il y avait sur une place Harle
un soir il était 3h du matin et il y
avait un petit dieu qui était là qui
j'ai mes petits enfants il m'emène au
bal et après le bal il m'oublie sur la
place bon et j'ai noté ça j'ai noté
cette expression cette espèce de
détresse qu'il y avait dans ce visage et
puis
le cette phrase là et il chantait tous
les garçons et les filles de mon se
promèent dans la rue de par ça m'a
semblé cette association de la chanson
et puis du tragique de ce vieillard qui
se passait dans dans son œil très
intéressant je l'ai noté j'en ai fait un
sketch et là c'est pareil c'est un
sketch qui fait énormément rire et au
départ j'ai jamais pensé que le public
allait pouvoir rire je l'avais donné
comme une parenthèse dans des moments
très rigolos d'une parenthèse un peu
tragique et finalement ce sketch finit
par faire rire parce que l'articulation
je peux pas y échapper à un moment donné
je vais à la pêche au rire ça peut être
une attitude ça peut être pe quelque
chose comme ça voyez de logique j'ai un
sketch comme ça sur un type qui se
touche en parlant comme ça que j'avais
vu à fosse tu la TA t tu je t une baffe
je t'envoie contre le mur et le mur la
tu bon ça c'est des petits gestes comme
ça voyez qui sont des tics de
comportement et à partir de ça plaf
après je fais le dessin complet dans
l'ensemble ce sont des thèmes qui sont
quand même pas très très drôles et
pourtant la sal rie voilà je parle du
nucléaire je parle du du du racisme je
parle de l'enfance brimée et cetera je
parle de la violence et tout ça ça
pourrait donner des thèmes graves ce
sont des thèmes graves mais qui passent
à travers le rire moi j'aime bien ça
j'aime bien ce mélange d'ailleurs je
m'aperçois que si parfois je suis un peu
fatigué un soir et bien le la marge est
tellement petite entre le rire et le
tragique que le public à ce moment-là se
retire et ne rit pas il faut que je sois
toujours en forme d'ailleurs mon
problème al le spectacle c'est quelque
chose qui est physiquement très dur
est-ce que vous avez un entraînement
particulier est-ce que vous vous
préparez non je mène une vie je mène une
vie assez assez régulière c'està dire
j'ai pas du tout la vie nocturne que
qu'imagine les gens vous savez il y a
une légende sur les les artistes la vie
d'artiste ça existe pas quand
j'interroge les gens d'ailleurs de mon
entourage qui font le même métier que
moi et je m'aperçois que c'est une
viille extrêmement sage parce que bon je
reste 2 he en scène je suis seul en
scène j'ai un spectacle qui est
extrêmement fatiguant très très physique
alors je m'entretiens c'est vrai que je
fais du sport je fais du jogging que je
surveille mon alimentation mon sommeil
et cetera c'est
finalement